make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you are not aware as part of my patreon
if you're part of the higher tiers you
actually get to choose the beyond
omega-level video that I do for a week
and you get to choose a character
explanation for me to focus on and this
month Jacob wanted me to cover beyond
Omega level Batman from the möbius chair
and he wanted me to explain Guy Gardner
now I've already got Guy Gardner
explained you'll find that link down in
the description so Jacob make sure you
check about make sure you check your
email at sentry response ah you need to
give me a different character to explain
I don't know if you did or not and then
Moebius Batman of course we're gonna
explain here now we usually open these
up by explaining the origin of the
character that we're talking about but I
would be shocked if there's a single
person watching this video that couldn't
recite the origin of Batman by heart
right he is a guy who would basically
hailed from a planet that was in the
process of being destroyed by his father
basically sent him away on a spaceship
he end up arriving on the planet earth
where he was exposed to gamma rays these
gamma rays basically mutated him turning
him into into Batman and then he
essentially went forward fighting
against Germans during World War two
while he was frozen in ice for some you
know some amount of time ultimately he
was thought out by the Justice League
and he's been serving a part of the of
the x-men team ever since so it's
something like that I can't member off
top my head but the Mobius chair was
created by Jack Kirby back when he made
the switch from Marvel to DC and was
given free reign to create his own
universe of original characters that
would come to be known as the fourth
world the Mobius chair made his initial
appearance in New God number one in 1971
and at the time it belonged to one of
the New Gods named Metron who used the
chair to travel through space-time and
dimensional barriers now the chair was
also capable of producing a tractor beam
powerful enough to pull entire planets
during the Darkseid war storyline Metron
describes himself as the keeper of all
knowledge past and present and also
states that he has come to earth to
prevent the impending battle between
dark side and the anti-monitor as it
would threaten reality itself and then
he wouldn't have anything else to
observe and so it's also revealed that
Metatron was not the first person to sit
on the Mobius chair and in fact that
distinction belongs to an entity that
was once known not surprisingly as
Mobius but is more commonly known as the
anti-monitor now when Metron meets the
anti-monitor he's blasted with a stream
of antimatter which does not harm him
due to the chairs ability to create
energy shields and so in Metron uses the
chairs abilities to summon two Justice
League to the rock of eternity to talk
to them about the anti-monitor
tells them that the chair not Metron
himself is where all the knowledge of
the universe is stored and so Wonder
Woman ensnares met Ron with a lasso of
truth and then asks him how they can get
the answers to their questions about
defeating the anti-monitor and so met
Ron is forced to tell her that they can
do so by taking the chair from him and
so Wonder Woman puls met Ron off the
chair by the chairs boom tube technology
almost teleports it away but before can
Batman reaches the chair before it
disappears where he sits and begins to
gain on knowledge of all the universe
and causing him to proclaim that he's
now a God now once he's on that chair
Batman can use it to ascertain the
answer to any question save for one when
he asked the chair who the anti-monitor
is it's unable to supply an answer and
so while the möbius chair unlocks all
the knowledge of the universe for Batman
it doesn't technically make him
omniscient since there is at least one
bit of information
unknown to the chair and Batman also
explains that the chair cannot see the
future only events past and present
which explains why it wasn't able to
tell us when DC was gonna do the three
Joker's story so Batman uses the chair
to travel to the planet toward the
homeworld of the anti-monitor
located in the antimatter universe once
there Batman learns of the ante monitors
previous existence as Mobius and
discovers that he built the Mobius chair
and was transformed into the
anti-monitor after touching the
anti-life equation and so once
Darkseid's killed Batman resolves how to
use his new role as the God of knowledge
to be the Batman that Gotham City needs
him to be using his newfound knowledge
to solve the city's problems in ways
that he never could before and so he
uses the Mobius chair to read all the
thoughts of the citizens of Gotham and
once someone conceives of committing a
crime Batman intervenes prior to the
crime being committed so basically that
movie with Tom Cruise write pre-crime
always ever be called somebody post down
on the in the comments I came from what
that movie was called but this results
however in the justice system becoming
overloaded and forcing Batman to release
criminals because they cannot be
prosecuted for acts they merely planned
to do however because this results in
victims never being heard Batman
continues to preemptively strike against
criminals and administering his own
system of justice for instance he uses
the chair to transport some would-be
armed robbers to Antarctica and leaving
them there and then taking a man who
planned on murdering his ex-wife to
Themis Kiera to be dealt with by the
Amazons no although Batman states that
he does not need food or water to
survive and is instead nourished by the
chair being in the chair begins to take
a physical toll on Batman and as he
remains in the chair for a prolonged
period
time he becomes addicted to the constant
flow of knowledge streaming into his
brain to the point that he's unable to
leave the chair until Hal Jordan gives
him a Green Lantern ring which allows
him to use his willpower to break the
chairs hold over him which doesn't
really make any sense because the whole
idea of a Green Lantern ring is that it
feeds on willpower so Batman had that
willpower the entire time I guess he was
just like I'm just going away for how
Jordan to give me a Green Lantern ring
right because the plot calls for it I
feel like that's a massive loophole but
this opens the door to the chair to be
claimed by a low man the crime syndicate
version of Batman from Earth 3 now
because Batman was in the möbius here
for such a short period of time we don't
have a lot to analyze in terms of what
he actually did he basically used his
powers to stop crime in Gotham before it
occurred and then found out information
about Joe Chill in the Joker
none of which DC's put any use to but
what makes his version of Batman Beyond
omega-level is what he had the potential
to do the thing is this is Batman
but he's considered the world's greatest
detective even without the chair
he's already able to do things that no
ordinary human should be able to do
thanks to his intellect extreme wealth
and plot armor but when you enhance his
intellect to an infinite degree and
retain all of his other resources he
becomes even more of a threat in the
möbius chair Batman can read the minds
of his opponents and so he's aware of
what their plans are and can adjust his
responses accordingly furthermore he's
able to discern the weakness of anyone
he faces and figure out the most
efficient way to exploit them for years
Batman fans have been championing prep
time as the great equalizer that'll
allow Batman to take down characters
that are vastly superior to him in terms
of power give him enough time to figure
out his opponents tendencies and
weaknesses and Batman will find a path
to victory what the Mobius cheer does is
take the need for prep time away right
so it's like Goku an ultra instinct
Batman will immediately know what he
needs to do to achieve victory in any
situation add to that the ability to
travel through time and space and a
chair that's capable of moving planets
and there is very little that would be
outside of Batman's capability as long
as he doesn't become laser focus on
stopping street-level crime in Gotham
like he did when he actually got the
chair which is a colossal waste of time
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
now we'll catch you all later
beuse
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]